sexual chemistry sure it's what brings a
couple together in the first place but
the science of bringing them together
without friction is today's tantalizing
topic as we explore what's inside trojan
tingly walk lubricant first let's get in
the mood with a little caulking since
being handy around the house is always a
turn-on and also because the dimethicone
in the common sealant is kissing cousins
with a sexy family of silicone polymers
hmm polymers for example short molecular
chain variants of dimethicone can be
found in breast implants while a rubbery
long-chain version of the friction
fighter comprises the silky skin of sex
dolls in trojan lubricants dimethicone
gets busy with dimethicone or and
additive in lotions and conditioners
that leaves a satiny coating on skin and
hair and both contain real logical
properties meaning they love to go with
the flow what really turns up the heat
though is vanilla butyl ether which gets
nerve membranes all hot and bothered by
penetrating them with calcium vbe also
has a hexagonal head identical the
capsaicin the molecule that gives hot
peppers their punch allowing it to spice
things up by pushing your biological
buttons without the sensation becoming
so intense you need a cold shower
instead trojan lubricants use menthol
keep everything cool
and tingly by triggering trpm8 an ion
channel protein that tells your nerves
to chill out literally which is a much
healthier dose of menthol than smoking
after sex so now you know what's inside
and we hope it was as good for you as it
was for us
feeling wired yet subscribe to the wired
Channel